في الدهون دي فعل جويه الاوكراني بمنظومه
باتريوت القديمه لن يجدي نفعا يقول الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الذي اكد ان الجيش
بلاده سيدمر هذه المنظومه الامريكيه
جدا لا يعمل كنظامنا الروسي 3 ما يفعله لن
يجدي نفعل انه يطيل فقط امدا النساء
في اسرع وقت ممكن عقد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي مؤتمرا صحفيه على الفور للرد على
الرئيس الروسي واعلن عن فرض حزمه من
العقوبات الجديده على 10 كيانات بحريه
روسيه
جديه لانهاء الحرب بالعمليات البحريه
الروسيه على الموانئ الاوكرانيه تفرض
الولايات المتحده اليوم عقوبات على كيانات
بحريه روسيه بما في ذلك تلك التي توفر
المواد الغذائيه والحبوب التي يحتاجها
العالم بشده
مع منح المزيد من الدعم العسكري الامريكي
لكيف لردع الهجمات الروسيه الجويه
والبحريه والبريه يبدل الرئيس الروسي
اللهجه ويؤكد سعيه لانهاء الحرب التي يتهم
الولايات المتحده بشنها على بلاده بشكل
غير مباشر